deposed as in a word I'd use but he is
no longer CEO I'm CEO so the role he had
he no longer has you know we created up
gave him a title that hopefully respects
what he's been to the business is
chairman emeritus I had good meetings
with Bernie yesterday and sincerely mean
you know what I said about hoping that I
can look to his help in advice as we
grow the business so he's an advisor and
to the board including me and we look
forward to his help but yes he's been he
no longer has the role he's had for
decades as CEO of the business now one
of the hallmarks of Bernie Eccleston's
reign was quite often playing divide and
rule among the teams you're offering the
team's a stake in the business how
widely do you expect that to be taken up
I'm not going to speculate me we're in
early discussions they've got meetings
in the coming weeks with the team's
about equity I mean what is clear is we
would like to create more of a
partnership with the teams about how we
grow the sport and what's the vision for
it long term the equity is just really a
part of that so I think the equity is
one way to align us more with the teams
but are over go over all Gaul in any
event is to create more of a partnership
with teams realistically with the
promoters no I'm with the sponsors or
the broadcasters of how do we grow the
sport you know for all of us and then
how do we share the benefits between us
of course increasing competition is
going to be central to that I mean
Mercedes are dominated over the last few
years how do you make this ball more
competitive as I've gone around it I'm
not an expert you know on the racing but
I hear the same things we want to make
the competition better the rules become
too complicated the engineers have taken
over from the drivers the engines need
to be louder and I'm faster cheaper you
know the answer to those things you know
to addressing those issues clearly
requires you know us to engage with our
partners and find solutions to some
degree they're issues in terms of cost
and revenue you ask you know some of the
teams does it make sense to spend what
you're spending you know on a team today
you know most will say no but it doesn't
you know
but the answer to how do you then
address it you know is not you know
simple so a fair allocation of revenues
would that mean for example the Ferrari
may no longer get the SPECIAL guarantees
on bonuses that it gets annually I don't
want to talk about any one team I think
that's you know I think those are
conversations you know we should have
you know in private I mean you know with
the party with the partners but you know
I think all our partners you know
broadly agree we can make the sport
healthier you know for everybody and
they all agree that for a sport to be
great it needs to you know it needs to
have the drama of competition then the
opportunity for an underdog to win and
you know but that doesn't mean when you
get to the track they're obviously all
going to compete as hard as they can
take advantage of whatever they can you
know to try to win so you know we need
to work with them to find these
solutions but I don't think it's I don't
like its productive I mean I found today
this is a sport and a business that
seems to like to talk you know like to
negotiate in the press and talk before
we do I usually like to do and then talk
act first and then explain later as
opposed to you know talk first and then
try and figure out if you can do
something now a lot of the circuits in
recent years some of the new circuits
that have been broader in countries with
questionable human rights records the
likes of Bahrain Azerbaijan and so forth
is f1 going to continue to host races
there I mean certainly the places were
in we're going to we're going to host
the races I mean we're running a sport
entertainment business it's a global
business that I think that's a good
thing for us to be creating a product
that you know that reaches out across
the world will run it responsibly but
you know we are in various places and we
run great races in many you know in many
places we're going to Amin I think we
want to make sure every race is
everything it can be we want to make
sure we strengthen our foundation in
Western Europe we want to make sure we
take advantage of opportunities to grow
in new markets like China or the u.s. we
have one race in each but clearly we can
do
there's only upside in those markets get
them for us we have some great races you
know in you know in places that are not
traditional markets and I think that's
all part of you know what we need to do
while we're running it responsibly